plus 10 and five plus three two games
if it's still one one of course uh the
match continues if this is one and a
half of to zero
it's over and then we have to
find the winner so there is an
armageddon game five minutes for white
four minutes for black and
draw odds for black and we see
the world champion going for nimzo
knight c3
sun move bishop b4 e3 castle bishop d3
and now yeah i played
knight f3 as well uh many more i meant
after e3 castles bishop d3
d5 a3 but yeah g5 a3 as well is
kind of uh it's a fashionable stuff yeah
c5 quincy seven
or b6 and um yeah it's very playable
um so d5 cd
and haddock is thinking he's taking on
d4
and now you have to you have to take the
knight exactly
otherwise it's not much but it's always
a bit a bit more pleasant for right yeah
galaga knight takes short castles knight
c6
this whole theory of course of course
the old move is some bishop c2 here i
think
bishop c2 trying to to get this battery
on the long diagonal
touching mate in one but forcing uh
black to to weaken a bit
there oh yeah knight takes d5 i was
going to say this
this has i think i've played this 25
then bishop e3 and you hope to put some
pressure with some quick knight
for some d5 options it was very safe for
white support
yeah exactly i think it is uh the main
move yeah
it is i remember yeah you will knight f4
here you cannot really take here because
that would be bishop h7 here 7 queen d4
attacking here and here better for
whites
for sure so i don't know maybe you go
bishop d6 you want to take and it's very
very slightly
better for yeah yeah not even better
once one is with white
like someone took on f4 and two
you grind computer says nothing of
course
but you can try to keep the two bishops
and play on
exactly the f4 plate yeah i had a game
like this bishop d6
some of rookie one i think i played was
some small pressure
also typical magnus choice it's a
defined pawn structure
well there's it looks harmless but
there's some tension
how do you call this structure in
english with the pawns the isolated
pawns on d4 and d5
is it is it the buffalo structure
he decided to take on f4 and play bishop
f6
well i don't know how it sounds to you
but it seems to have
less fun today with magnus games and we
add in the two classical games
which were incredibly exciting both of
them
don't look that's hopeless to me no but
of course
very very little b3 we should be one who
kb1
26 and magnus winning a pawn
simple chess as simple as that
is it is it as simple as that he seems
to think so
here's a3 here's my genius trick
knight takes d4 here comes
the genius i'm not sure how genius this
is
you know what trap your queen you know
what sami would do here
eight he would do he would take on a
seven and be happy
would he be happy nah maybe
black is directed no yeah before i'm not
sure you hold that blockade
and it didn't see your trick it seems
not sure if my trick was any good
tonight
what can i go i'm not sure i don't see
it
that was good that was good
bishop d4 okay v8 you are so good equal
bishop b5
queen 5 queen six some miserable
rockending
yeah that was missed i think by both
players actually because magnus would
never enter that if
he sees it also on the other side a4
queen b5 i would think about
way more chicken way to play h4 queen g3
looks very normal
it's okay knight c6 is not good i have
to play knight a6 but if i don't do that
i'm losing a pawn
no risk some small pressure he can play
against pieces
it's exactly what he wants very
manageable
f6 yeah h4 will come most likely that's
almost
automatic in this in such positions you
just put upon h6 and then you see
sometimes you may want to take taken
rook c8 h4
played by magnus
no it's really very very difficult to
give an advice for blackrock c8 played
let's have a look before as well yeah i
wanted to mention that b5 actually
is winning a piece so yeah you gotta
do something about it i think we need to
cover the b
b5 square then trouble on the king side
exactly exactly between these seven you
can
just high five and
that's all it's probably no time to go
back to the hotel room
it's very very hard to manage the
schedules fish 45 as a clear idea
one hour that's a hot dog and a massage
he was thinking he played b5 now h5 27
and now magnus is taking some time he
feels
the important moment it's time to decide
on a plan
no it's not much of a plan i was
dreaming of
a queen of the way then g435
shook e5 that's how he is planning to
become a gun master
yeah if he finds funding
and the check yeah for a piece is fine
okay
we can quickly see three yeah magnus is
not having any of it
i can see three so
so solid just controls all the squares
okay if i go king f7 what do you want
now
f3 g4 queen g3
probably out of it all of these things
quest seven i have quincy sixteen
king king king i king of so sorry
not yeah yeah i could have five played
okay
g3 you can't take on h5 no that's quincy
eight
yeah check
collecting the knight
what does menis want two pawns and two
checks
for free i think queen e5 g3
played instantly careful now
king king f8 played after 27 quincy two
lying on uh uh g6
king f8 played protest queen g5 alley
we have to protest the french way huh
i don't know french newspaper
[Laughter]
i go here you're looking at certain i go
quintex b5
bad news server
only one square for the knight knight c7
27 check collecting the knight
this is game one over and who knows
my queen stop giving that night away
poor knight but what is
too late queen g4 okay it's a good move
though
only one in that case yeah magnus
carlsen
after a tough match looks like now he's
in prime position to make it through to
the next round
it's not over
but indeed 96 played h6
will be played as well i believe
or maybe some clever
you come back you want to give a check
check take
also possible but h6 feels so natural
for white
hard to imagine something can go wrong
of course if you take on d4 i just have
quite a 7 check collecting the knight
all the tactics seems to be in white
favor
oh i was you know that i was scared yeah
i thought for a moment because we were
giving all these checks that the king
was on g2
yeah at the same hallucination because
immediately you think not a fart check
no and
i thought queen d1 king g2 knight of
four then queen takes eight
that's not legal um
queen e4 by voitershek
centralizing winning
by centralizing he's probably not
winning
where's y2 27 check
king g8 let's say you just take some
porno what you do
you will take him as much as the next
guy
yeah he's about to take and it's a pawn
yeah knight g5 bishop takes
g5 21 check king g2
queen e4 king h2 and the checks expire
then fg5 yeah
between f3 that's so clear we need three
well yeah okay quintet yeah
we're only one for up
prolonging that match because he lost
the first one exactly
michaels keeps giving some checks i know
i can see the engine says
completely winning queen ending you're
never that sure right yeah
everything's covered and one of your
pawns is running
to be honest i didn't expect king f7
looks scare seven
but i don't mean i might be yeah
important
now we can wait but i don't know
bring the king probably swinging it so
b3 go a4
looks winnie
your point is let me just wait
you wait and if a5 and f4 you can still
look at that
wow but then it must be winning he must
have calculated it all
takes takes oh he was hesitating
off oh that's that's the game he knows
the structures
so that's
it's also just supernova a4 a4 and take
on b5
egg
king a3 i already have king c4
i i should say i can lose a move a4 king
a6 i go kk3 where
king ah king b6 oh i take
no no he's gotta figure it out yeah and
watershed resigns
while the world champion advances to the
next round